welcome to this video a 15 minute game
against Bushido man from from Germany
and probably a fan of the German not
really okay it's not a fan of the German
rapper he's in his 50s yeah okay so he's
interested in the original art of
Bushido
it seems let's see what am I doing here
is playing III and deform now okay I can
just take and player positions typical
of the exchange French takes on d5 yeah
probably that's the best way to play to
move like d6 is probably just as a
weaker I can play E for and f5
okay come on let's do that it's not
terribly exciting but at least it's a
it's a straightforward position but I
know what to do yeah c3 it's a rock
solid
yeah like wants to get some some
asymmetrical things going let's see
Bishop g4 I can this is always an option
playing for playing for long castling
and I can I can try that
there's also ideas with keeping the King
on yet for the moment and only later
decide where to put it so I can do all
these moves and depending on what he is
doing I can decide if I Castle long or
short
they don't trust long castles so much to
be honest let's just get rid of the
bishop and play a positional game yeah
yeah probably with the night so we have
a symmetrical almost symmetrical pawn
structure with the open Aoife this is
not terribly exciting but I think I
already accomplished something his best
piece the bishop on d3 has already
exchanged for my c8 bishop which is not
really a brilliant piece and they are
also slightly better developed so he's
probably intending to go night III yeah
it's not not so much so I can do about
it right III are always really intending
to to to absolutely exchange everything
off okay
yeah the French exchange is not not
known to lead to very exciting chess but
it's it's solid of course what to do
yeah my knight on c6 is not good I need
to I need to regroup it it's only
looking at d4 and before and this is as
you see is firmly covered so I'm trying
to get it to g6 maybe g6 or well if four
would be nice of course
maybe I had some way to to bring it to
reform okay let's see how to G for was
interesting where do I go then probably
I need to go here not a good okay
I'm freeing these six for the night
maybe this way preparing Knight to e4
yeah and I don't want to exchange even
more you can play 95 now but I will kick
him would have six just one move later
of course I must be a bit cautious
because of the Queen on b3 move like f6
must be considered carefully like f6 I
put a knight on e4 he takes it with his
rook this would be a very embarrassing
okay just return
at least this is not completely dead
this position nighty form would be
really nice to play let's see what what
he is doing okay
so much for so much for the smooth Jim
yeah it's really not very exciting but
yeah it happens mm-hm maybe I shouldn't
have played f6 I don't know
check
yeah
so Quinn takes maybe maybe I can go here
it will be one dome okay maybe if this
irritates them no night-night see for
sure but what what exactly is this
accomplishing Queenie - just probably
yeah okay this will be a long ride in
the end game it's really not much else
possible here Queenie to a go king of
seven and Queenie second
guy managed to really exchange all
pieces off so d610 if I go to d6 this
even Bishop d3 not not very great Knight
e3 years Queenie towards completely
pointless if I go to b6 e mattress
plague 95 yeah it's not yeah I need to
body to get something something
imbalanced him maybe I can if he goes to
c5 Quincy eight community to king f7
maybe I can go Bishop d6 turn intake or
something to have some kind of imbalance
here
now Bishop d6 and just take that night
against Bishop would be quite okay here
it's a rather close position it's not
not an advantage but at least it's a
kind of imbalance
yeah maybe he will retreat because he
does not want have had want to have any
imbalance it's not bad he can just play
night back to the three and then maybe
Bishop d2 f4 or yeah I mean it's it's
just them just very equal exactly
championship to d2
how to do anything here maybe here if
you bishop I can I can go Queen c7 and
Knight f8 to e6 or something yeah maybe
this has really like pressing water out
of stone that's really a bit crazy to go
into them exchange French as black if
you don't must do that I mean it's it's
okay if you play the French and he he
takes whatever just need to play that
but I went into this rather rather
willing lately and especially in this
time control it's a it's really boring
but I came let's let's regroup night
three six this is okay I'm controlling
there for now and only six it's it's
it's it's nicely positioned town this is
okay okay he's putting some pawns on
dark squares this is good news not
entirely terrible but not helping okay
let's see if he wants to continue in
this way a five yeah he does okay so the
knight has new squares now on b5 for
example should I go them
ok let's let's see what the night is
maybe able to accomplish on b5 or
possibly c4 later
b5 a3 c4 might be a root then oh yes
quite some points on dark squares yeah
yeah ok I will take that but but still
maybe you know I can play that first
okay
hmm okay I'm not really sure where it's
going to be six it does not look too
great okay if I go here and why this
plane Queenie three to exchange more I
can go to f5 or that one that's not not
a big difference and they have queen bee
one as an irritating move yeah
f6 King f7 this this kind of moves that
that that are very helpful is not it's
not able to invade somewhere uh-huh this
is not very active so let's let's invade
and see what this invasion is going to
go into it complet if we place night c5
I'll just take it at the moment he
cannot do it at all because I would take
and take c3 okay
he really wants to trade badly but I can
go here which introduces wait just wait
for a moment if I take well now taking
us taking us not good enough this is
better
it keeps the pressure on attacking the
knight on a4 and I also have this
additional IDM to play Bishop g3
yeah he probably needs to move the night
and let's see if I go Bishop g3 now what
is he doing
Queenie to him
unfortunately this is not this does not
seem to win the game Bishop g3 Queenie -
I can trade everything off and take c3
he will take b7 I play Knight a - yeah
maybe it is winning actually all night
b5 at the end
taking on d4 which may be winning but
it's somehow it feels like I should I
should I should have more here even I
don't see I don't see something now
hmm after night p7 at the end of this
line I just see that I have he has night
98 second taking c6 that's a shame
okay let's let's get to this
this structure night against Bishop this
should be should be useful and how to do
that now he's got some some pawns
already on on dark squares
yeah the knight on d5 is not it's not
badly placed but it's not it's not ideal
I want to remove it to e6 and towards
the center
he goes Queenie - I'm not going to
exchange Queens I'm trying to keep them
on queen bee threes for for example or
queen bee one question is p1 or b3 b1
problem keeping this this pin intact so
that it cannot move the bishop and
there's maybe 96 F for d3 this kind of
this kind of route yep here we go
yam Bishop d2 was a normal-looking move
what about what about deform look like
queen edge wonders probably completely
useless right yeah the desert is useless
okay let's just let's just be an
annoyance and ask him what is going to
do okay okay Queen age six he has an
active idea even
I wonder if d4 is an idea get this get
this traded d4 takes Queen B - but it's
not really it's not really convincing
okay maybe I can do this I can there
well Queen age sixes it's not really
comfortable okay but I can just play
King g8 right we can just break in red
it's not it's not so so dangerous okay
the idea is if he takes I'm just playing
come on Quincy fourth suppose the idea
Quincy form intending Knight see 725
this should regain upon I mean I don't
think he can can keep it
what I mean is Bishop c3 Knight c7 and
then 95 threatened this could be could
be an idea
they don't think I'm really risking
something Queen age 6 I can take on d4
first and then I also have King gh if
everything else fails to protect h7 so
easy to say what you should do you can
go to various end games Queen C 3 for
example Queen D find but okay this is an
end game where I can can try to to win
at least yes got some points on ducks
class but it probably should be it wrong
yeah Quincy 3 it's maybe not so bad I
can I can
mmm I can try to keep the Queens on with
Queen a 2 and then Knight to d5
maybe yeah let's do that
try to fight I think Wendy for I mean
this is an is a comfortable end game but
I'm not sure that I can win it here's
lots of space and so there are some
tricks now here Queen d3 neither form
can easily happen
yeah probably if he goes to see one yeah
I can take before then but it's not
really yeah it's it's a little bit
luckier of course yeah but I won the
Queen here keep probing my design keep
probing and trying to muddy the water
but I think it's probably about equal I
mean it's not easy to play oh yeah when
I get to be four pawn and then the
computer gives me a very big edge yes I
think I get the pawn that's right um
I can I can just take it and then try to
continue the knight is just the better
piece here that that's clear but I
thought yeah it's not it's not easy to
play this disposition I was thinking
that this is that this is not enough to
win I mean it looks nice because he's
got those points on the color of the
bishop but how do you really get ahead
you can get it to d5 the night and then
what it's probably a draw probably and
this is just just very annoying to play
yeah yeah as this is of course helping
enormously you must play something like
that and then we play this position this
is of course a different animal if we
look at the Queen trade and let's say he
moves the King something like that now
the Queen trade is losing because he's
got those weaknesses now that I had that
I'm easy to attack so he cannot trade
this is losing directly
Queen moves and then maybe him yeah yeah
this is this is a substantial advantage
it is it is I can activate here take the
pawn of h5 + f5 as there's two possible
ways to harass the King yeah yeah this
is this is something this is something
now yeah it was some very very grinding
type of game where you try to accumulate
some small things and to try to set
problems and I think I've I did a decent
enough job to do that okay thanks for
watching